will tell us about the geometry of
secure computation
so um everyone here so thank you you all
so today I will be talking about uh
secure multi-party computation
in particular how geometry can help us
perform secure multi-party computation
so to establish this connection with
geometry we actually came up with
something A New Perspective on how
security manifests in interactive
protocols
based on this connection we have been
able to motivate
new research problems in geometry
in particular real algebraic generation
and finally and most fascinatingly
we can actually find physical processes
in nature
where secure multi-party computations
exist naturally
without any notion of security
so first thing I must remind you the
stock is in the context of information
theoretic cryptography
so everyone has a b space or record
okay every function that you can compute
efficiently can be efficiently inverted
there is no one-way function no public
encryption no OT or Beyond
okay
in some sense in the context of this
Workshop this is the most minimal
assumption that you can come up with and
we will tell you how to do meaningful
cryptography in this model
so I will present results from a couple
of our papers one that was published
last year one currently under submission
and I will actually cover several
results that are currently we are
proving in our ongoing projects
is my colleague from maths department
and Hamid and high are my graduate
students I recently graduated
he is in the postdoc Market very strong
candidate please you can consider
okay
so uh
in in this Workshop I do not need to
motivate secure multi-party computation
but let me just give a couple of
sentences secure multi-party competition
is a Premier Technology that is expected
to bridge the data utility and privacy
charge
and it does so it helps parties compute
uh securely over their data it outputs
only the intended output and reveals no
additional information
and it does so by leveraging several uh
resources like computational resources
network resources Randomness resources
and cryptographic resources
and these additional resources create
overheads which in fact are the
bottlenecks to its adoption so a natural
uh question here is to how to minimize
these uh overheads and we want to
perform secure multi-party computation
with minimal overhead
so what to expect in this talk we will
be talking about round and communication
complexity of secure multiparty
computation
so given a task we will uh we will
and a bound on resources like round
complexity or a communication complexity
we will show how we can compute that
task within those resources or I will
give you a proof that it cannot be
performed securely in those resources
so our
solution strategy is a new geometric
approach and we introduce a new uh the
New Concept of generalized convex hulls
to establish this connection uh
um a very interesting consequence of our
work is that now we have systematized
the space of all uh secure computation
protocol
so we can let loose a computer to find
the most optimal solution for us
the way I like to put it is uh we are no
longer limited by human Ingenuity and
creativity in designing secure protocols
a computer can solve it for us and write
the paper
[Laughter]
the second thing I wanted to emphasize
is that I highlighted that I can give
you proof that let's say there is no
five bit secure protocol for a
functionality
this is a lower bound information
complexity lower bound
traditionally people come up with very
smart people come up with various
slick invariance and then they prove
that hey five bit protocols cannot
satisfy that
we have automated it it is as simple as
testing whether a point lies in a set or
not okay
this is the topic about informational
theoretic cryptography okay two party
secure computation in the information
theoretic plane model parties have
access to P space oracles
okay
so the first part of the talk is
completely geometric
I will just talk about geometry and
towards the end I will warn you before I
introduce security
and that too will work only with one
representative example
okay so before I introduce our notion of
generalized Hull Let me Give A New
Perspective on how VC convex Hulls
so let's define an initial set of points
on the plane s0
I will Define a geometric action
that allows us to do the following
given any two points PQ in the old set
it allows me to add the line segment
joining PQ to the new set
okay so let us assume S 0 is our old set
and we apply this geometric action on
this old set to create the new set
observe that I did not insist PQ to be
distinct you can assume P equal to Q
in this particular case the line segment
joining PQ is the point P itself so what
it implies is that old set can be copied
into the new set
if you now consider distinct PQ let's
say you consider these two as B Q then
you join this line in the new set so red
points are the points which showed up
for the first time in the new set black
points represent points that were
already there in the old set and were
copied to the a new set is everyone okay
with this representation and color
coding
everything is fine okay
everyone agrees
yes you can choose both and you can
write it to operator
and everyone agrees that we could not
have added any more points to S1
okay so now we apply the same geometric
action again on S1 S1 is our new old set
and the new set first of all we can copy
everything
and observe that anything in the
interior of the triangles are red
okay
any questions about this
is quite the dimension which is on the
plane
very good question if this point was up
you would have had a tetrahedron at this
point
when you say you say point so initially
we just had four points so it was yeah
not infinite times
here yes
but you pick your favorite to PQ and
keep doing it
so you can this is how you define it
it's different okay it's not actually
going to do that let me state it in this
way that uh apply the geometric action
iteratively twice to s0 you will get S2
yes
foreign
there are no new points that show
once no new points show up they can
never show up
so our objective is to study the
evolution of this set under this
geometric action
and what we can show is that it
stabilizes and when it stabilizes it is
a convex Hull of the uh or initial Point
set
is this okay
but how do we prove that uh it
stabilizes when does it stabilize okay
so towards that objective there is a
very powerful theorem character there is
theorem that says that if your initial
Point set lies in an ambient dimension
of Dimension D ambient space of
Dimension B then any Inter Point inside
the convex Hull is a convex linear
combination of at most D plus one points
ambient space means if in three
dimensional if your points were on a
hyperplane ambient spaces too exactly
so a very simple observation every point
in s0 is a combination of one point in
s0 every point in S1 is a combination of
at most two points in S zero every point
in si is a convex linear combination of
at most two to the power I points
therefore this must stabilize by
at the log B plus
okay so this is how we see uh convex any
questions any doubts it's fine
you can write everything
regardless of the number of points right
yes that's a very good observation that
the answer is independent of the num
size of the initial Point set S zero
it only depends from the dimension of
the ambient space
okay so now let me Define what's
generalized conviction
let's start with the same initial Point
set
however our geometric action is looks
similar but it allows us to join the
line segment PQ and add it to the new
set
if and only if the points are axis
aligned that is either their first
coordinates are same or second
coordinates are same
is this okay
so again we can choose P equal to q and
in that case I can add still at the
oldest Point set to the new part set no
problem with that
and now note that the only new line that
I can join is the choosing P equal to
this
if I choose this p and this Q they are
not access aligned so that line cannot
be added to the new set
is this okay
make sense
okay again we can copy over old sets to
the new set
and we can add this new line
okay set
the line
we can copy over the new set
and now everything gets added here
does it stabilize
okay I have run out of space that's a
very good guess right
so it stabilizes
you can show that the round where it
stabilizes does not depend on the
dimension it depends on how many points
are there in the it may depend on how
many points are there in the initial
Point set
that's it oh very good question I was
about to differs my quiz question
suppose points are in general position
this is my s0 can you tell me what is S1
because there is no one
it's good
this is amazing okay
okay so what are the research questions
in Geometry given s0
a success description of the set aside
and determine if at all this sequence
civilizes
actual questions
yes
why not can you always prove this uh
just open it
in two Dimensions I can prove that it
stabilizes in finite steps please with
the last slide for something that is
this is the open problem in mathematics
no
capacity is over 3000 years old
very fast
okay
so I promise that this actually this
kind of problem opens up a wormhole that
connects your research and information
complexity with geometry research so
here is the translation table
given a functionality
is there a five bit protocol for that
functionality that translates into a
membership query
I can design a query point which depends
on the task and you have to answer
whether it belongs in the set S5 or not
it's a task is like a function yes a
functionality I will Define this more
formative
I will Define that it will depend on the
task
s0 subscriptors will apply the geometric
action five times very good question
so so there's qtask and this is your
task uh killed this query point and it
depends on the task that's what I wanted
to
secure computation no what is a zero
right there's two things
point and it depends on the tasks
that's it right the s0 also depends so
why is it not written on the slide it
it's a short
only
if there is a five-week protocol
I would like to design it right
we need to construct the faster
basically or the generative Story how
this point came into being
satisfied
from that we can reconstruct the CPU
protocol
if no
then I need to prove or convince someone
that there is no five bit protocol this
is typically very challenging to do
all I need to do here is to show that
the class the straight point is outside
the set
yes
set is not wide you see there is bundled
on this company algebraic complexity
like the geometric capture indicates
like the mechanisms of randomized
communication
let's do it
so you don't care about communication
complexity and things like that wrong
complexes
Alice can speak to consecutive branches
this problem also translates to round
numbers okay the geometric actually is
slightly more complicated that's why I
did not uh
with an example
yes um
uh when you're moving to the next s does
it need to match up
accessories
match everyone but one this is a very
good question
um
so uh in general
they have to match on first let's say a
first part of the year uh our anger
information will be very high dimension
States first few must match or second
few must match this
will be near map instead of a linear
function
okay I wanted to go to the last one
typically we in communication capacity
there is no security
input to Bob right and Bob can perform
the computation on behalf of both and
sit back the answer
so the communication complexity of this
is bounded by the size of the input
output domains of the task which has
nothing to do with how complicated the
task is
um
can we show such a bound here in
security as well this translates into
showing that this sequence stabilizes
this is the communication the insecure
communication complexity no uh this is
secure communication the analog of it
will be to show that the sequence
stabilizes in some finite number of
steps
okay
so let me establish some connections
so this is connected to a
motion of convexal known as the related
convection it is slightly similar to
something known as geolistic convexor
but it is not that okay I want to
specify that this is relative convex
Hull and it is parameterized by the
question
it's parameterized by surface C let me
Define the surface C
pick a point
on the plane X and Y
lift it up to height Z that is the
product of the two coordinates X Y so
this gives us a curved hypersurface
we can lift our points at S 0 to this
curve hypersurface and the new geometric
action says that you can join the two
points PQ if and only if the line
segment joining PQ is contained on the
curved hypersurface
okay
significantly for this particular choice
of C two points the line segment
lies on the hyper surface if and only if
they are accessible Act
okay so for you can consider the general
scene for this particular scene the
notion of relative conventional
coincides with what we are studying
okay
and most interestingly this is something
that we came to know very recently
um
folks in partial differential equation
they motivated a new notion of convex
her known as lamination convex her
this is parameterized by a set laminar
so you are given an initial set of
points and you can join the line segment
joining PQ
to the new set if and only if
P minus Q is in the set Lambda
okay
and they are interested in how this set
evolves
and they post this as a new research
problem in algebraic geometry
if you fix Lambda to be the X Union of X
and the y-axis
then you can only join points to the set
if and only if they are accessible
so now secure computation protocols
manifest as Solutions of natural
processes you do not need a computer to
define the security of it
it exists in nature so the way I like to
look at it like whatever we did in our
work someone smarter can come and prove
something better
our proof will be superseded by theirs
but this collection can stay okay
any questions at this point then I will
switch to gym uh
yeah
so what do you mean by access online
the first even with the subscript one of
you subscriptions that they have the
same text access
aligned I heard access aligns
who Dimensions
aligned I will explain the gender
questions
geometric part is finished
no in this this connection this oh how
it connects back to here no I win one of
those ah this is the one you can Define
before yeah okay slips
I'm not going to talk anymore about any
of these things geometric parties
does it help us this connection between
compressible
to understand better communication
complexity or or just nice observation
of beautiful observations
it's just a nice part I do not see how
far it is
you'll study a problem at the
intersection of information complexity
and cryptography we want to understand
the communication complexity of secure
computation
the model is very simple we have two
parties Alice and Bob Alice has an input
Little X Bob has an input little y
and their objective is to sample a input
Z that both agree on according to a
probability distribution f x y so I want
to highlight f x y
is a probability distribution over a
sample space
okay
it can be deterministic it may be
randomized
and we are considering honest with
previous adversaries the simplest and
most Elementary murder
and the question is is there a b bit
secure protocol for the function f
all the distributions F of little X
little y are public everyone knows the
task that they want to perform
okay
what was done before
if the output is determined by the
inputs X and Y then I will say that the
function is deterministic this is the
seminal result of chorus and Bieber
where they characterized all
deterministic functions that have two
parties secure computation protocols and
since 1989 this problem was open the
characterization for randomized space
okay
and the non-triviality is to deal with
both inputs and randomized output
if you do not have a randomization that
kushlovis did it
if you have do not have inputs then it
is kind of awesome that is easy right
Alice can tell the coin tossing outcome
to work
because they're semi honest okay those
parties get the same output yes Alice
can toss and give it the answer
and there are ways to do this
paper
work
is possible and when it's not right yes
I will give them
so uh I want to explain this using an
example
I want to remind everyone what
kushlovitz characterization was I will
use the famous uh example of auctions
where Alice can bid either one or three
Bob can either win two or four and we
want to compute the winning bid if the
bid is one and two then the winning bid
is two if it is three and two the
pinning bit is three if Bob bids four
the answer is 4. so you do not need to
remember the labels all you need to
remember are the colors
okay not even the values okay
peace
so let's see what's going on
if I know that the output is 4 the
winning bid is 4 then I know for sure
Bob's input is for
if it is not then I know Bob did not
beat four so Bob can just announce
whether he wants to bid for
or not
is this clear
this is a secure information to reveal
condition of the fact that Bob is not
bidding for
the output reveals Alice's bid so now
Alice can reveal whether she is bidding
one or three
this is the secure protocol for options
this is identical to Dutch option where
you count down from top and people raise
their hands whenever they agree to build
that price
is this new it's counting down
okay everyone is comfortable
the question is
why can't Alice speak first what happens
if Alice speaks first so let's think
Alice reveals whether she wants to build
one or three
that is her input is lower row or the
upper row in that case observe that if
Bob had decided to bid for he will
figure out Alice's bit right
if the bit is four for Bob he should not
have figured out whether Alice wants to
build one or three so this protocol is
insecure what is now the summary we
cannot split monochromatic regions
monochromatic regions have to stay
together for security
okay so here is question of his
characterization if you can take a
matrix
and decompose it such that
it is monochromatic region preserving
that is it is secure and at the end of
the protocol you have monochromatic
rectangles this is a this is a property
of information theoretic protocols that
whenever you end the protocol you must
have rectangles yes so the color in The
Matrix just based on the output yes
so yeah this is just like coloring color
four was blue
so there are examples of functions
that cannot be decomposed as such
although everything is a rectangle here
Alice cannot break this or break this so
that she cannot speak and selectwise
here is a more much more fundamental
problem there is a region of
monochromatic color that is not even a
rectangles no way there can be
foreign
so the problem is this approach we could
not see how to extend it
to the randomized approach so the
strategy we employed was the following
first of all we had to realize that we
are not push limits
we are computationally bounded we cannot
come up with a conjecture and try to
verify it that's how could she with it
it's conjecture and there is a technique
of how to secure protocols proceeds and
we verified that that's how that's the
only way it can work we did not have any
such conjecture
so we bound back time to pre-1989
okay and we need a new perspective to
start
and recover which result
and let me tell you
what is the key perspective that we had
so let me introduce our framework first
of all I assume we assume that Alice and
Bob are picking their inputs private
inputs uniformly at random and
independent of feature for perfect
security this does not matter
okay
suppose the protocol has evolved to a
partial transcript Tau
and Alice is the one who is supposed to
send the next message she can either
extend it to uh Tau l or Tau R
indicating whether the protocol should
evolve towards left or towards right
this is one bit message that Alice can
set
now since Alice is sending a message
here Markov constraint says
that Alice's message
cannot reveal any additional information
about Bob's input
let's be very precise Bob might have
revealed some information about his
input
prior to reaching here
but Alice's one bit cannot add any other
information to Bob's partial what we
know about Bob's private inputs
so let us Define condition of this
transcript Tau what is the marginal
distribution of Bob's inputs let's call
it Rota
and here we have row Tau L and rho Tau r
so what can we conclude
this must be identical to this because
Alice cannot reveal any additional
information
and this must be equal to this
so we say that these two partial
transcripts are siblings
because they have the same Bob marginal
distributions
okay Alice can reveal input about her
input but no information about Bob ship
so we'll probably kind of nodes siblings
I want to emphasize one thing here
markov's law is absolute
there is no finagling around it okay
there is no statistical version of
markov's law
is that clear
is it okay
there's no statistical version
it is absolute and perfect it's a law of
nature
so this is where we decided to start we
do not know how the protocol is going to
start from top and proceed so we decided
to go at the bottom because we know that
the output definitely will be either
three two or four we know that for sure
if the output is 3 we know that Alice
input must be the top row and Bob's
input must be the left column so these
indicate the marginal distributions
if the output is 2 we know for sure
Alice's input is lower row and Bob's
input must be the left column
if the output is 4
Alice Bob's input must be the right
column and by security
both of these inputs must be equally
likely for Alice
any doubts any questions at this point
this was our starting point because this
is what we know for sure right at the
end of the protocol people find out the
output of the protocol
make sense yeah okay look these two are
siblings
Bob marginal distribution is the same
so Alice could merge again
and they can merge in any arbitrary
Lambda 1 minus Lambda ratio I'm just
writing down the half half ratio okay
okay so this was s0
this is S1 there are no more signalings
now these two are siblings
they can be put together
by both
because Alice marginal distributions are
identical
okay
make sense we've recovered crucial this
protocol
and thankfully this approach extends to
randomized
okay
so one thing I have not told you
is we are bonding to siblings right I
have not told you whether it is secure
or not
we prove that it is secure
so that is our new perspective on how
security manifests
a protocol a secure protocol is one in
which the leaves
or at the end of the protocol
the protocol is secure
and every internal node of the
transcript
must respect the Markov constraint
that is it
yes
it's a really good question
okay let's scale at this definition
where does security manifest
only the base case
this geometric action is independent of
security emotion
so if you want to use substitute semi or
security by differentially private
secure protocols just change the base
case
this Remains the frame so it's a unified
perspective on how security manifests
okay this is another
Insight that these points can be
geometrically embedded let me be very
Frank
the difficulty was in finding one such
thing but now that we have found one I
do not think that is the real challenge
there are many more embeddings that we
have found after that
so that is not the fact interesting part
interesting part is that it is
geometrically encodable what I mean by
this is that if you take two points and
encode it in Lambda 1 minus Lambda then
the corresponding Point Falls at exactly
that point on a geometrical
so here is a strategy
we start our our geometrical bedding
will look like this we will have
marginal distribution of Alice involved
and the function encoding
and we can combine two things if a equal
to a prime or b equal to B Prime
we start with base case and keep
building these our Target query point is
uniform distribution over X uniform
distribution Y and encoding of the
function f
and there is a vivid protocol if the
query point lies in this set
you can recover the protocol from the
pass tree and if the query Point does
not line the set then
there is no perfectly secure
that's it that's the high level of work
any questions yes the dimension will
depend on
the range size of input domain of X size
of input domain of Y and size of input
domain of Z typically in this research X
size of X size of Y size of Z is taken
as constants
Leaf node is we know the output right
yeah every output defines one point in
essay
okay should I move it
and or you set a and b to be the
marginal conditions
it's a perfect security it is unique
right so I know that uh all both you
very fully likely at the end if uh
output Theta is two times more likely
for input one than this than the
ratially written through I'm talking
about yeah that's what it said the
marginal distribution will be two third
one third if one output is more likely
twice more likely for one
thank you
okay have you seen such a connection
earlier
it is such various disparate Sciences
yes
this connection that was established
with distributed computing with topology
they establish a connection using which
we were able to bring all the fancy
techniques from topology and bring to
beer on distributed computing problems
okay
we can do the same thing in our case
but the most exciting part is
the math part in our case is not known
it is motivating new research
okay so let me quickly jump over these
parts these are this was a randomized
example uh
let me quickly go to the conclusions
part okay so I told you this question
about whether something
stabilizes or not very recently
we found that there is a set of size
five that is there are five outputs
and Alice and Bob have one bit input
in this case the sequence does not
stabilize
so there is a function
such that
there is no perfect secure protocol
it can only have statistical security
protocols
and this result
any bounded number so there existed
function here take any B if you have a b
bit protocol it will be x minus B
insecure
so this actually falsifies the widely
believed folklore
it was widely believed that a
the communication complexity should
depend on just the input output domain
size and the complexity of the Computing
a function could be contained locally to
parties just like communication
complexity case
however
this was also true for deterministic
functions however it is false for
randomized Solutions
and our example is optimal because if
you have four outputs any function with
four outputs it has at most four bit
protocol we can show that
okay five is the optimal number okay
the other thing was
it was conjectured that if you have a
statistically secure protocol then you
can error correct it into a perfectly
secure one
not anymore
this function does not has only
statistical secure protection
protocol that computes like a it's a
distribution over five outfits okay
so you sample from this if I have 0 0 so
F 0 0 will be a distribution over 5
outwards and we sample according to that
so in your geometric embedding you have
a dimensions for each one five times
every possible x minus y y minus y and z
okay each one of them gets a dimension
and you like we need to put them
together in all of these different
dimensions and sometimes if an output is
not supported over everything then you
just have a zero weight or something
like that there is a the encoding is
tricky
I will not go into that but the point is
uh
it's not for anything fancy sure
I do not consider these pets it was very
difficult to pull off on the first time
okay is that crucial that it's real can
you replace it with rational number oh
very good question
um the counter example that we have has
denominated 35 for example
so no it's no irrational
you can consider Russians
very good question
you help me sell this paper better
so if this does not stabilize can we
prove that it converges to some limits
does it limit there is a limit set
if there is a limit sir can be computed
and our conjecture is yes yes to both of
them okay
the interesting part is that
solving this conjecture actually
needs you to solve equations of this
form
linear inequalities
where these numbers are not real numbers
they are convex shapes
okay and greater than equal to one shape
being greater than equal to another
means that this contains the other
and Max means this contains both this
and this
and you can find the smallest solution
X1 X2 X3 that is a solution to such a
system
then uh you would have come up with the
limits okay
so as you can see we are doing algebra
using the over the polyhedral semi array
with the containment inequalities
reminds you of something very famous
something very really cool nowadays
topical algebra
They have Max Plus algebra instead of
plus multiplication algebra
okay
so if
at the we are able to use tropical
algebra to resolve this problem
so I think this Confluence of NPC with
topical algebra could be called NPC in
the tropics
that will I think once we resolve this
it will give me a very warm feeling
the conference and the place
I think that's what they have been doing
however the last step algebraic geometry
Workshop that I mentioned
okay with that I would like to conclude
my talk again thanks to my co-authors
and uh yeah like without them this
question would not happen possible
[Applause]
you can take further questions
so if the functionality doesn't have
cannot be implemented
obviously
oh this is a very good question
if there is no statistical secure
protocol can we show that it can be
broken back constantly
actually we can show that
what's the constant for every function
it will depend how close it is to the
ideal shape the closer it is the Lesser
insecurities if it falls inside zero
insecure if it is near the shape that I
was talking about the query point if it
is near then it is less insecure if it
is far it is
so I'm not trying to understand the
question the question is about
statistical security or yeah so if at
query point is not in the Set uh how
insecure is it okay it is at least sort
of a distance motion from this which
knows that it is less insecure the
further it is
again all I need to do is change the
base case nothing changes
I I I do not know
very good question like I would like to
understand for example op complexity of
a function then I can give them OT
oracles right I have to change the
geometric complexity so that you pay one
dollar every time you use it okay if I
can come up with the geometric action
for that then we are done
so
[Music]
it is
so uh let me be very Frank for one year
we try to prove it my students did not
believe in me and they were trying to
dispute okay so while we were trying to
prove it we were trying all these
techniques on heli number uh
for this section we're trying to show
that there is a property nice properties
for them
and uh yes there will be open problems
because they do not stabilize it
the option is that you don't know
I don't know the answer and because the
shapes might not stabilize
which is good right like I would have
otherwise written on the wallpaper now
I've been like more
but though I really am very sad that it
does not stabilize because otherwise it
would have been a really beautiful
property
because I really am disappointed with
that result
okay great
amazing videos